botaram a todos iam dizer que nos
últimos tempos
muita gente não tem perguntava ou por
causa do brete significaria o fim do
euro para a europa essas fronteiras
nacionais pelo menos para o reino unido
por causa da catalunha que significaria
a discussão da espanha eo resto através
do estado nacional ea questão do pequeno
estado por causa da eleição de trânsito
que rompeu com o tratado as alterações
climáticas rompeu com os tratados de
comércio livre designadamente com o
pacífico tpp e com a europa o tite e
portanto que estaria voltar ao
isolacionismo e portanto seria no fundo
o fim da colonização
estamos a assistir é para definir o nome
em várias áreas mas em particular este
do brasil da catalunha e pronto
o que significaria o fim da colonização
eu devo dizer que para mim eu não sou
grande fã desta expressão globalizado
eu prefiro a expressão mundialização que
a expressão que aprovados francesas usa
isso pode parecer pretensioso francês ou
afetas à mas se nós pensarmos na origem
das palavras e é importante que para
nossa discussão globos globe em latim
significa esfera globo
mas basicamente uma massa e crítica de
pessoas é uma novidade e portanto é um
conceito muito neutral
é o conceito de mundos mundo é o
conceito do planeta no conselho do
universo é o conceito do mundo tal como
nós temos em português mas que têm ao
mesmo tempo um sentido ético e estético
por mundos mundo é tim também quer dizer
olimpo assediava véu é no fundo o
conceito de cosmos quiserem cosmos é o
mundo ordenado consertar ordem com
harmonia com blusa por isso nós falamos
em cosmético conhecimento e que nos
ajuda a ficar mais bells mas de acordo
com a linha do cosmos e por isso nós
dizemos que o contrário do mundo e o
'mundo é que o que é feio ter sujo que
não é esse
realização e veio numa globalização
ética estética uma visão que tem um
sentido harmônico mas o provável é que é
que o que vamos usar aqui é um tema
habitual à globalização para que não
haja nenhuma aventura política quando
falar do brad pitt ou trote ou da
catalunha
nós temos a dizer seus bons são bons ou
maus
estamos apenas tentar perceber se os
representam uma inversão um processo
inverso negou essa ou se ao contrário eu
são da consequência uma continuação e
porventura na expansão da própria
globalização
por seu turno talvez seja melhor para
essa nossa conversa
primeiro por brad pitt muita gente
pensou breve é o contrário da
globalização e por quê porque no início
dos anos 90
muitos pensavam que o exame seria fazer
por grandes blocos regionais
a europa união europeia a nafta na
américa do norte méxico e hawai estados
unidos 1 a 0 no pacífico a china a índia
no fundo até que a lei do conflito de
civilizações uma obra muito importante
no início dos anos 90 do samuel k
tentando choque de civilizações
a suíça os ortodoxos a seleção ocidental
latino-americana a chinesa é muçulmana
indiana
a companhia previu se nós fizermos um
preview os atentados do 11 de setembro o
jihadismo como um fenômeno global é e
meio que ele falou eu não tenho lugar
mas o fenômeno global e portanto o
preview história um prédio inteiro
comprar isso essa ira do reino unido num
espaço de integração global que a união
européia
mas é provável que se nós pensarmos
online em breve foi feita exatamente o
contrário
o credo helena é grande divisa dos
blacks attias os radicais queriam sair
do euro países mais radicais é o globo
grita e os acham que a europa a união
européia
ao contrário do que se pensa é uma
espécie de clausura de prisão
é que está em cápsula vazia em causava a
grã bretanha e ela para ser global para
ter sua velha dentro de compactos um
grande
perry mas que os teriam maioria digamos
muito mais horizontal
ela precisava ser em outro país por um
espaço global e portanto ao contrário
suspensa
o breque que foi feito em nome de
globalização e não contrai ao globo
entretanto nem toda a gente tem essa
raiva mas uns ambicano é viver
legalmente em londres a 20 dia voltar no
fim do brete e qualquer inglês
o britânico que vive no continente
europeu há 10 ou 20 não podia votar no
prédio
as regras eleitorais eram bastante
quando vais e muito pouco no país porque
uma pessoa do sri lanka domingo deixando
protestava estivesse há dois anos em
londres podia votar eo inglês tivesse a
10 anos em faro em málaga ou a
influência não podia votar mas vamos
agora olhar para a catalunha
se nós vimos a catalunha na escócia a
flandres todo nove tal ea zona de milão
e veneza chamada lombardia eo vêneto
piemonte chamada pane é o norte tal e
querem ser independentes estão com
movimentos separatistas
então o que também está com um
particular muito forte
muita gente diz que está ao contrário da
globalização é o regresso às fronteiras
nacionais
quando estamos na europa tentar alargar
e globalizar aparecem movimentos
particulares regionalistas luca listas
isso os acionistas que quiserem
construir outras fantasias e reconstruir
um mundo de pequenos estados
não será isto encontrar na globalização
ora nós temos que pensar talvez um pouco
melhor é que o que a europa ser sempre a
união européia a partir do seu centro de
bruxelas foi europa das regiões
no fundo este uma linha seca tática
entre a união europeia ea sociais que
era tirar poder aos estados nacionais
bruxelas irá por cima as regiões tenham
por baixo e portanto é pouco e pouco
havia aqui uma estratégia quanto mais se
urupá isa a política quanto mais o poder
é um poder europeu mas o poder é um
poder regional e - é um poder nacional e
portanto estava sedado
força se nós quisermos estas chamas
estava cenários instrumentos de poder o
que aliás cada corpo com a própria idéia
de globalização quando surgiu nos anos
a ideia forte de globalização nós
falávamos também em localização ou seja
as grandes diretivas são globais nas
realização prática a implementação a
aplicação dessas diretivas tem que ser
local
se eu tenho objectivos mais gerais novas
em bruxelas
a adaptação às regiões têm que ser mais
particular mais cuidado porque os
objetivos são marginais
isto é com localização e para entrar com
um efeito que é um efeito muito
importante é que eu chamo efeitos
estereofonia global
pensei na escócia quando cayman e os
mais radicais que não contra o cambra
diziam mal dos céus bruxelas o primo o
reino unido em edimburgo em glasgow em
aberdeen na escócia
o que as pessoas pensavam era aquilo que
uns ingleses estão a dizer de bruxelas é
aquilo que os dias pensando londres
é aquilo que eu já mostrei a fome global
hoje os políticos quando falam tem que
ter presente
estou a falar num sítio mas vão ser
ouvidos em vários tipos os humanos têm
dois ouvidos foram feitos para o mundo
exterior forma uma vibração do som em
frente dá um tom do som diferente e
portanto quem bruno dizia para bater o
pé bruxelas estava a força é de hamburgo
na escócia ou por exemplo quando a
senhora merkel o senhor chova desenham a
unha a finlândia ao ar da áustria não
vão pagar as dívidas dos países doadores
do sul na catalunha na flandres né pra
velhinha e tal eu estava a pensar em
1900 as dívidas do sul e cauê a silvia
inaptos cantando e nós vamos pagá las da
luzia e na flandres nós vamos pegar o
estado social da parte francesa que fala
francês danone é estereofonia global
eu estou fazendo afirma sá num sítio
mas ela está sendo vida de outra maneira
com outro tom com outra versão com outro
ritmo noutro sítio e portanto não serve
sentido este clube é essa aliás penso em
vai se nós pensarmos mas é evidente que
se o sul da catalunha em 1980 ou é mesmo
em 90 ainda não pára o carro único só
assim é que o mercado como uma união
aduaneira é uma coisa muito mais simples
é muito importante para também estar
dentro da espanha é muito importante
para mim eu amo para turistas dentro da
vitória é muito importante para a
escócia está no reino unido porque esta
está estes três países eram estavam
dentro das maiores potências industriais
na altura das novas potências econômicas
na altura mas se eu agora tenho bruxelas
estão em barcelona eu não preciso de
madrid bruxelas fala por mim no palco
global
se eu estou em busca não preciso de
londres tem números elas e se eu estou
em milão eu não preciso de romã
eu tenho bruxelas aliás aconteceu
exclusiva pelo ser tratados de comércio
livro está em bruxelas a união européia
e os estados não tem nenhuma competência
nessa áreas e portanto o que fiz à
catalunha chipre malta e um seguro
o juvenil lituânia são países muito
menos fortes como economia muito mais
fraca
nenhum primeiro ministro no conselho
europeu e tem um comissário da comissão
europeia porque o ec representado por
madrid
os em 3d com a minha catalã podem não
corresponder exatamente aos interesses
da economia espanhola no seu todo e por
que não é ter uma voz ativa 77 milhões e
meio de pessoas e existem 400 mil a 600
mil 800 mil
porque nós temos sub-representado
explica que está em linha com a
globalização ainda
depois temos o flamengo mais difícil que
talvez trânsito portanto realmente que
vai numa lógica de isolacionismo na
américa força cortar com os tratados
firmados por tópicos tratados econômicos
cortar com tudo isso mas agora pensa em
o que faz o tom alto a droga o clã é o
que eu faço
é política global todos os dias através
do twitter e não é um presidente que
assina é as ordens executivas e creche é
um presidente que passa a manhã à tarde
à noite twittar ao tuitar está a usar um
instrumento de organização está a fazer
política global
não é a primeira vez que o pai eo véu em
amsterdão ou em pano um táxi em coimbra
e o condutor lhes o tributo tem razão
porque está seguindo no twitter
por isso eu vou fazer política global eu
não é um público acionista eu estávamos
na e colonização
para vender a sua visão das coisas e
portanto ainda é uma consequência de uma
expansão da globalização e é muito
importante nós temos isto presente aqui
é importante os presentes aqui porque
também no trato e existências tráfego
bom e por isso eu queria técnicas
o digamos é é assimetrias na compreensão
da sua mensagem
os que suportam completamente e outros
que não suporta e isto no fundo transe e
se quiserem assim a conclusão é
conclusão é que tanto brasil como forma
de se proteger o catalão como até mesmo
tranquilo mesmo como doutrina ou prática
política eu são conseqüência são o
prolongamento natural da globalização e
por tecnologização é irreversível ela
não vai parar evento diz quadro global
que nós vamos mover isto eles
argumentaram futuras fronteiras não é o
regresso ao estado nacionais não vai
acontecer o que vai acontecer é uma
reconfiguração da política dentro deste
plano e aí eu chamo a vossa atenção para
ter o que eu considero ser o grande
problema é o grande drama da política em
termos globais é fazendo uma luz que não
sei dizer
max ana não marxista uma análise de
negócios gás
eu até prefiro sanz quiserem usar os
montes que é o toque viu que são
leitores da minha preferência que tem
que fazer uma análise política baseada
nos órgãos sociais e nas diferenças
sociais e econômicas
gosto de deus
os cães vão chamava-se monte eu chamava
se toque em homenagem a este histórico
mas é provável que colocando kaká qual é
o grande conflito que está aí presente a
propósito da globalização o ajustamento
do conhecimento
nós temos uma classe e informa incluir
em uma classe de infantis cleide uma
classe que escolherá cosmopolita que
acha que está no rio verde bpamb o
facebook o interlar micro fora e outra
acrescenta excluída e fora disso
e são estas duas que estão com esse
grande diferença pois é que o max se
estivesse escrever uma obra não
escreveria das kapital o capital
escreveria gás visando o conhecimento
porque é scatto que vai originar com
certeza muita turbulência e muita
confusão e um dia me for verdade as
revoluções nós não fomos capazes de
abrigar nem com ela eu explicar este
fenômeno e é o que explica porque é que
as votações vão nesse sentido e o texto
na vossa atenção para curió grafia dos
políticos nos anos 90 para ser um
político de sucesso conhecer como é o
justin rondou o primeiro-ministro do
carnava ou marrom pessoas fitness muito
bem vestidas o banco muito garante que
poderiam apresentar enfim pessoas meira
naturalmente um after shave um perfume
em qualquer suporte publicitário nas
ruas split system sucesso não são assim
tem toda uma característica todos têm o
cabelo desgrenhado pronto
glória jogos sim o pt grilo wilders é
ordem dos 10 km das ilhas exóticas para
12 anos têm um ar
eu tenho são muito mais canais são
pessoas mais pegajosa as mais antigas
rosas não vestem bem e eles têm são mais
vulgares são mais viris bem comentários
muitas vezes pouco atrativos são pessoas
de facto que não pertencem a essa idéia
do os deuses do álbum póstumo de deus do
olimpo
ou então vai enfim do caldeirão do mar
negro
portanto um lado mais informal se quiser
envolvem por que por que exploram os
outras pessoas enquanto que os outros
pulavam os anos das pessoas e se
explorar os temas das pessoas e portanto
nesse sentido aqui também uma mudança de
visão tanto é que o que eu diria que é
facto grande challange o grande desafio
de tepco global que não vai regressar
atrás
ao contrário do que muitos imaginam
porque mesmo aquilo que nos parece que o
processo está a ser feito de acordo com
os pressupostos relógico regularização é
que o que nós temos realmente conclui
dar é isto é como é que nós vamos tentar
integrar e trazer para a área do
conhecimento um conjunto enorme na faixa
enorme da nossa população que está fora
dela
isso é que é o grande desafio dos
políticos em nível global hoje em dia é
conseguir reduzir essas assimetrias do
conhecimento é tensa
eu não estou a dizer muitas destas
pessoas que justamente estão no lugar
dos informes concluídos não têm acesso
às tecnologias do contrário elas usam o
facebook elas usam as redes sociais o
que elas são utilizadores e críticos
possível
elas são mais utilizados por essas
tecnologias do que tem o controlo das
mesmas e portanto é fundamental estar
atento é este é este viria fosso que
existe entre aqueles que está em
conhecimento e aqueles que não têm
conhecimento e perceber que a sec vai
ser o grande indutor de mudança social
no futuro de vocês enquanto isso eu acho
que estamos a fazer pouco e por isso não
estou muito otimista mas deixe no fundo
se quiserem uma palavra final que uma
vez ouvi em coimbra no mundo que não é
nada global há mais 30 anos é que pode
ser que ao fim
os pessimistas tenham razão mas pouca
minho os otimistas divertem se muito
mais
[Aplausos]
[Música]